بكتيريا اكله للحوم ستنتشر في الولايات
المتحده ما ذكرته ليس سيناريو من فيلم رعب
بل حقيقه مرعبه تهدد حياه الامريكيين خلال
السنوات المقبله جامعه استانجيريا في
المملكه المتحده حضرت من ان هذه البكتيريا
ستنتشر في انحاء امريكا بحلول عام 2040
بسبب تغير المناخ من ارتفاع درجه حراره
المحيطات والاحتباس الحراري لكن ما هو هذا
الكائن الحي الذي يهدد البشر هذه
البكتيريا السامه تتكاثر في المياه
الدافئه والمالحه مثل مياه الفيضانات
الراكده وهي الاكثر شيوعا حاليا في المياه
الساحليه بولايه كارولاين الشماليه يصاب
الناس بالعدوى من خلال الجروح المفتوحه او
الافات الجلديه الاخرى التي تتلامس مع
مياه البحر او عندما ياكل شخص ما سمك
النيئا او غير مطبوخ جيدا عدوى هذه
البكتيريا تنتشر بسرعه بين البشر ويمكن ان
تلحق اضرارا جسيمه بلحم الانسان ومن اشهر
الاعراض الناتجه عن الاصابه بها تليف
الانسجه الذي قد يؤدي في بعض الاحيان الى
بطر الاطراف تشير الدراسات والابحاث الى
ان واحدا من كل خمسه اشخاص مصابين بالعدوى
يموت في غضون يوم او يومين من اصابته
بالمرض